Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Sag mal, was hast du vor 25 Jahren am 11. September 2001 gemacht?
Also eigentlich wollte ich Pong spielen.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 559 und ihr habt es schon gehört, es ist der 11.
September 2026 ja und damit jähren sich die Ereignisse und ja,
vor 25 Jahren wolltest du eigentlich Pong.
Spielen das waren ganz wilde Situationen die USA wurden von einem vollständigen
Idioten regiert Kann man sich heute überhaupt nicht mehr vorstellen.
Irre, ja. Ja, Zustände. Das ist einfach...
Und das war's. Das war das Einzige, was sich damals beschäftigt hat.
Ja, die sind jetzt alle voll. Ja, 11. September.
Du wolltest eigentlich Pong spielen. Das hab ich irgendwie gespürt.
Und deswegen haben wir da auch was vorbereitet. Du bist dann irgendwie nicht vorbeigekommen.
Da kannten wir uns auch noch gar nicht.
Das stimmt. Project Lincoln Lights, ne?
Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen. Genau, vor 25 Jahren haben wir irgendwie
Blinklight eingeschaltet und ich weiß noch sehr genau, wie wir da irgendwie
am Abend saßen, weil am 12.
Hatte er ja dann der CCC Geburtstag und das wollten wir ja irgendwie feiern, den 20.
Geburtstag und ja,
durch eine Verkettung von verschiedenen Ereignissen kam es dann dazu,
dass wir die Gelegenheit hatten, diese Lichtinstallation da zu bauen und da
haben wir natürlich dann fleißig auf den Tag hin gearbeitet und in der Nacht vom 10.
Auf den 11. September haben wir es dann hinbekommen. Da war es dann fertig und eingeschaltet worden.
Ja, und dann zehn Stunden später war dann die Aufmerksamkeit woanders.
Das haben wir auch extra gemacht.
Ja. Ein Inside-Job, um euch die Aufmerksamkeit zu stehlen. Ich bin da auf jeden
Fall sehr in mich zusammengesungen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man sich das jetzt heutzutage überhaupt noch so vorstellen
kann. Aber es war ja ein ein,
Also als die Meldung reinkam, brach das Internet zusammen.
Und zwar wirklich. Also es war dann sozusagen, keine Webseite war mehr erreichbar,
alles war vollkommen überlastet, weil einfach die Webseiten von damals für so,
den Moment eines gesteigerten Interesses an einem Weltereignis überhaupt keinerlei
Vorkehrungen getroffen haben.
Also auch gar nicht konnten. Also die Technik in dem Sinne war, glaube ich, nicht da.
Eine Spielerei für Computerspinner darin, hat doch keiner in der Zukunft gesehen.
Ja, aber auf einmal war es interessant. Und natürlich stürzen sich auch alle
aufs Fernsehen, wo ja dann 24-7 eigentlich nur noch Flugzeuge fliegen in diese
Türme und die Türme brechen zusammen, gezeigt wurde.
Aber das Internet war halt irgendwie platt und so war das dann auch bei uns.
Wir saßen dann halt da irgendwie im Büro und wollten gerade irgendwie die finalen
Vorbereitungen machen oder haben die finalen Vorbereitungen gemacht für das ganze Event.
Und es ging nur noch unser Text-Chat.
Das war das Einzige, was man da irgendwie noch benutzen konnte.
Aber so ein sonstiger Infrastruktur im Internet war nichts zu erreichen.
Das war wirklich echt interessant.
Naja, those were the days. Projekt Blinkenlights, also sozusagen dieses,
wer jetzt noch gar nicht weiß, wovon ich überhaupt rede.
Wir haben halt die Gelegenheit gehabt, im Haus des Lehrers in Berlin,
diese Lichtinstallationen zu machen, indem wir dann diese 144 Fenster von innen
mit alpiner Weißfarbe angemalt haben, Baustrahler dahinter gestellt haben,
zehn Jahre alten 486er da angeschlossen haben, der ganz viele Relais hat,
klickern lassen und dann waren wir halt in der Lage, da so monochrome Matrix-Animationen
laufen zu lassen und das war irgendwie ein ziemlich cooler Hack,
fand ich, weil wir haben das Ganze in fünf Wochen,
von Von der ersten Idee bis es wirklich lief,
hinbekommen mit relativ wenig Geld.
Und man konnte dann halt auch Pong spielen. Und das ging dann erstmal ein bisschen
unter natürlich bei dieser Nachrichten-Weltlage.
Aber hat uns dann ein halbes Jahr ganz gut unterhalten, bis wir dann am Ende
Februar des folgenden Jahres dann abgeschaltet haben. Aber so in dem halben
Jahr ging es echt gut ab und das war eine schöne Zeit.
Es gibt da ja,
diese, da hattest du mir ja mal erzählt, was ihr dann halt auch mit dieser Installation
gemacht habt, wie ihr sie dann quasi, wie habt ihr denn das Herz da drauf gemacht?
Ja, also wie wir auf die Situation reagiert haben.
Ja, genau. Ja, aber das war natürlich irgendwie eine merkwürdige Situation,
dass genau in dem Moment, als auf einmal so diese Welt-Terror-Paare ausbrach
und alle in so einem völlig,
man kann sich, ich weiß nicht, wie du das damals wahrgenommen hast,
aber es waren ja auch alle so super nervös dann, ne?
Also es war so dieses so, oh Gott, fliegen jetzt überall Flugzeuge in Hochhäuser,
sind wir jetzt hier als nächstes dran? Was passiert mit unserem Fernsehturm?
Also das hat alle irgendwie völlig irre gemacht und natürlich hast du es dann
auf einmal mit Befindlichkeiten zu tun.
Und unser Modus war, wir hatten jetzt gerade mitten in Berlin,
in der Hauptstadt, da stand ja auch noch kein anderes Haus davor,
so direkt mit Blick auf den Alexanderplatz auf einmal so einen riesigen
Lichtbildschirm, auf dem man ja nun im Prinzip beliebige Nachrichten hätte kommunizieren können.
Und wir hatten dann diese Ausstellung eröffnet, wo dann die Leute selber so
Filmchen machen konnten, weil man konnte sich ja so einen Blinkenlights-Editor
runterladen auf seinen Mac und dann konnte man schön mit der Maus irgendwie
so Bilder malen und dann so Frame für Frame sich seine Animationen zusammenbauen.
Und du kannst dir natürlich vorstellen, was wir so für Animationen bekommen
haben innerhalb kürzester Zeit. Und ich dachte mir nur so, die zeigen wir jetzt
nicht, weil dann drehen alle total durch.
Und eine junge Japanerin, die hat dann dieses Herz gemacht. Einfach nur zwei
Frames blinkendes Herz.
Das ist also klein und in der Größe, ne? Wie so ein pulsierendes Herz, klein, groß.
Genau, klein, groß, irgendwie babam, babam, einfach im richtigen Timing.
Und das war auch, ich meine, Herzen kann man auf verschiedene Arten und Weise
malen. Das stimmte einfach von den Proportionen.
Und das wurde ja letztlich auch unser Logo.
Und das war irgendwie so von all diesen Animationen, die da entstanden,
das, was mich irgendwie sofort am meisten berührt hat.
Und weil halt alle so crazy drauf waren,
haben wir uns dann entschlossen erstmal eine Weile abends einfach nur dieses Herz blinken zu lassen.
So nach dem Motto, Leute, es wird alles wieder gut. Ja.
Peace, love, happiness. Irgendwie entspannt euch.
Das mag euch jetzt alle extrem gestresst haben, was jetzt auf der Welt passiert
ist, aber wir sind hier und kümmern uns darum, dass es euch wieder gut geht.
Und das kam auch irgendwie, glaube ich, so an.
Also viele Leute haben mir erzählt, dass sie das irgendwie enorm beruhigt hätte.
Später haben wir dann natürlich diesen ganzen Animationskram,
der uns geschickt wurde, dann Stück für Stück in die Playlist mit aufgenommen
und dann wurde es halt immer lustiger und irgendwann haben die Leute dann auch
ihren Humor wiedergefunden. Aber es war schwierig.
Schwierig damit umzugehen, weil du auf einmal auch so eine komische Verantwortung
spürst. Also mir ging das zumindest so.
Man kann natürlich jetzt auch sagen, ich blase euch jetzt hier irgendwie voll
mit unserem Kram, aber in dem Moment ging das irgendwie nicht.
Dann später gab es dann auch noch so Demos, die dann auf dem Alexanderplatz
stattfanden. Die haben wir dann auch mit passenden Einblendungen,
so Pi-Symbole und sowas, graniert.
Also man konnte auf einmal so das Geschehen kommentieren.
Nachts zumindest. Und das war schon eine neue Rolle, in die man auf einmal schlüpfte.
Also ja, es war schon eine irre Zeit und nach einer Weile wurde es dann auch als Kunstwerk,
entdeckt und auch ernst genommen und gefeiert und wurde auch von Berlin schnell mental eingemeindet,
sodass einige schon richtig entrüstet waren, als wir dann irgendwann angekündigt
haben, dass es damit auch mal
ein Ende hat, dass sie davon ausgegangen sind, das wäre jetzt immer so.
Das wäre ja Berlin und das gehört so und das müsste so sein und natürlich bleibt
das jetzt für immer so. Doch klar.
Das war ja schlimm genug, dass hier was anders war. Jetzt wird das schon wieder weg.
Ja, das war schon strange.
Aber wir hatten ja dann die Gelegenheit, das dann nochmal zu machen in kurzer Zeit.
Also wir sind ja dann sozusagen von von unbekannten Hackern zu internationalen
Medienkünstlern aufgestiegen innerhalb von wenigen Monaten,
und wurden so rumgereicht und es gipfelte ja dann darin, dass wir dann gleich im Jahr da drauf im.
Auch im September, Oktober, dann das Ganze nochmal in Paris in schneller,
höher, weiter gemacht haben, an der Französischen Nationalbibliothek und das
war natürlich der totale Knaller.
Und da waren wir dann halt irgendwie der Opener von der Nuit Blanche,
die in dem Jahr überhaupt das erste Mal stattfand, sozusagen.
Also pranken dann auf allen Tageszeitungen und ja, das war dann sozusagen Teil
2 der ganzen Geschichte.
Und es gab noch ein Teil 3 2008 dann in Toronto, dann haben wir da nochmal auf
die City Hall gezogen und um all das zu dokumentieren, habe ich mir viel Mühe gegeben,
das auch auf unseren Webseiten mitzuführen aber leider ist mir so in den letzten
Jahren die Webseite weggegammelt und deswegen habe ich mich jetzt nochmal,
bemüht und mich mit meinem Freund Claude hingesetzt und die Webseite komplett
neu gemacht, sodass es jetzt blinkenlights.de wieder gibt und das alles wieder dokumentiert ist.
Heute, am 11. September, 25 Jahre nachdem das alles stattfand.
Das ist irre, dass es schon so lange her ist. Kommt echt vor wie gestern.
Ja, und Zeitenwende, ne?
Ja, Zeitenwende. Auf jeden Fall. Die Welt wird ja nur in Vor- und Nachblinken als gedacht jetzt.
Ja, sehr schön.
Blinkenlights-Seite finden wir dann in den Show-Notes, oder was?
Ja, blinkenlights.de.
Ja, dann freue ich mich drauf, mir das nochmal anzuschauen.
Aber das Haus des Lehrers hast du jetzt nicht nochmal geweist.
Nee, das ist ja mittlerweile alles so Bürokram.
Ich meine, wir sind danach auch nochmal da wieder rein und haben zwischenzeitlich
nochmal so eine Aktion gemacht und wir waren ja dann, als es umgebaut wurde,
das fand ich besonders putzig,
hatten wir dann auch das Bauschild, was sozusagen immer da stehen muss,
wenn du so ein Umbauprojekt machst oder ein Neubauprojekt, musst du ja sagen,
hier wird folgendes gebaut, lalala und dann hat man ja in der Regel auch immer
so eine Zeichnung des entstehenden Werkes.
Und dort gab es dann halt auch eine Zeichnung des entstehenden Werkes und wir
durften dann aber in das Bauschild selber nochmal Blinkenlights reinbauen.
Also während das Haus des Lehrers umgebaut wurde, war quasi auf dem Bauschild
selber auch nochmal ein LED-basiertes Blinkenlights sozusagen als letztes Abschiedsding.
Wir hatten auch lange diskutiert, ob es irgendwie möglich ist die Installation
so dauerhaft in dieses Gebäude mit einziehen zu lassen, aber da gab es dann keine Möglichkeiten.
Tja. Wird das eigentlich wieder genutzt inzwischen?
Was, das Haus? Ja, klar. Seit es umgebaut wurde. Es wurde dann halt entkernt umgebaut.
Und seitdem sind da halt Büros.
Seitdem wohnt der Lehrer da wieder.
Ja, genau. Und jetzt wieder ordentlich unterrichtet.
Ist das Haus des Lehrers?
Ja.
So interpretiere ich das.
Ursprünglich hieß es auch Haus der Lehrer. Wurde dann aber irgendwie zum Haus des Lehrers.
Ja, weil der Lehrer halt keine anderen weisen Männer neben sich duldet.
Das kennen wir doch vom Lehrer.
Der Lehrer ist ja plural.
Morgens hat der Lehrer recht und am Mittag hat der Lehrer frei.
Sag mal, da war doch irgendwie noch die Toten Hosen haben dann noch ein Video
drin gedreht, oder nicht? Ja, habe ich das falsch in Erinnerung.
Nur die Liebe zählt.
Im Entertainment gar nicht. Die Attraktion war ja das Haus, dass da irgendwelche
Punker da noch reinkommen.
Tja, ich hab's nicht so mit Rockmusik und deutscher Musik. Es kam halt so die
Anfrage und die wollten das halt irgendwie machen. Es ist ja so einiges passiert in der Zeit.
Und dann haben sie halt irgendwie dieses Musikvideo drin gedreht.
Da sieht man das Haus dann auch sehr schön. Kann ich auch nochmal verlinken. Tatsächlich.
Und es wurde auch zum Schluss noch.
Liebe Kinder, wenn ihr jetzt nur die Liebe zählt, googelt und da kommt Kai Pflaume,
dann müsst ihr noch Campino dazuschreiben.
Und das heißt nämlich, das ist aber tatsächlich, das Lied heißt nämlich nicht
nur die Liebe zählt, das Lied heißt, was zählt.
Ach so.
Ja.
Stimmt, das Lied heißt, was zählt, du hast recht.
Ich hab das ja auch gegoogelt. Gerade Kai Pflaume war nicht da.
Den gibt es auch noch, ne? Ein paar Sachen haben sich gar nicht geändert.
Ist vor allem, was ich am schönsten fand, ist, sagt dir Symphonie einer Großstadt was?
Was ist das?
Symphonie einer Großstadt ist ein sehr alter Film über Berlin.
Also Berlin, Symphonie einer Großstadt. Und das ist ein Film,
der 1927 von Walter Ruttmann gedreht wurde über Berlin.
Und der hat gar keine Handlung, sondern der zeigt nur Szenen aus dem Alltag in Berlin.
Ah, okay.
Und dazu läuft so eine Symphonie, also so ein durchgehendes Lied und du siehst dazu halt das Ganze.
Und da ist auch Blinkenlights drin?
Nee, da ist Blinkenlights nicht drin. Aber 2002 wurde eine neue Version von
dem Symphonie einer Großstadt gedreht.
Auch von diesem Walter Rothmann?
Nee, nicht von Walter Rothmann.
Der hat doch wahrscheinlich 33 bis 45 überhaupt nicht überlebt.
Ja, das kann schon sein, dass der das nicht mehr mitbekommen hat.
Auf jeden Fall wurde ein neuer Film 2002 gedreht und da ist Blinkenlights dann tatsächlich drin.
Der ist tatsächlich 1941 gestorben.
An den Folgen einer Embolie. Also im dritten Reich eines natürlichen Todes gestorben.
Also der neue Film ist dann von Thomas Schad und ja, da kommt dann das Kacken.
Ah, ich verstehe, warum es ihm vergönnt war, eines natürlichen Todes zu sterben.
Der hat nämlich 1933 den Propagandafilm Blut und Boden gemacht und kurze Dokumentarfilme,
für nationalsozialistische Kriegspropaganda.
Oh Gott.
Ja, und war eine Inspiration für Leni Riefenstahl. So, ich würde sagen,
wir kommen jetzt zum nächsten Thema, Tim, weil das...
So, eine schöne Filmempfehlung.
Wenn du noch was anderes zu empfehlen hast, kannst du gerne...
Den habe ich noch nicht empfohlen. Ich habe ja den neuen empfohlen.
Ich weiß nicht, was Thomas Schad jetzt so macht, aber gucken wir mal.
Okay, wir müssen einen Fehler in der letzten Sendung korrigieren.
Auf den uns mehrere Leute hingewiesen haben. Und zwar hatte Stefan gesagt,
dass der Gerichtstermin in Döbeln am 18. November sei. Das ist aber ein Feiertag in Sachsen.
Und damit konfrontiert räumte er ein, dass der Gerichtstermin eben am 19.
November ist und nicht am 18.
Also alle, die da jetzt schon ihre Busfahrten hingebucht haben,
müssen nochmal umbuchen.
Und ihr habt schon gemerkt, der Tim hat sich jetzt sehr lange an einem Thema
festgeklammert, was überhaupt keinen Neuigkeitswert hat, 25 Jahre alt ist,
aber halt eine angenehme Erinnerung,
weil das Wochenende keine so angenehme Erinnerung für uns hat.
Und zwar gab es eine Wahl in Sachsen-Anhalt, die ein,
denkwürdiges Ergebnis hatte.
Und über die jetzt natürlich viele rätseln und die tatsächlich ja dann das demokratisch
orientierte Leute so ein bisschen beklommen macht.
Vor allem, wenn man sich so Zitate des Spitzenkandidaten, der.
In dieser Wahl am Abstand die meisten Stimmen gesammelt habenden Partei anhört.
Hast du zufällig so ein Beispiel parat?
Unsere Position ist ganz klar, dass wir sagen, wir verteufeln nicht pauschal,
Produktion von Rüstungsgütern, weil wir bei späteren Remigrations-
Der eigenen Stabilität und auch der Landesverteidigung, das ist uns bewusst,
das fällt nicht vom Himmel.
Und das ist der, wie gesagt, Wahlsieger mit Abstand, ja, Ulrich Siegmund,
der mit seiner Partei knapp verfehlt hat, die absolute Mehrheit zu bekommen.
Und jetzt sind natürlich alle News-Seiten, das ganze Internet voll mit.
Jetzt können alle erklären, wie es soweit gekommen ist.
Müssen wir natürlich jetzt auch. Ja.
Ich würde sagen, der hat halt etwas geschafft, was Friedrich Merz nicht vergönnt
ist. Also Friedrich Merz ist ja,
eine Fehlbesetzung. Man dachte eigentlich so, okay, Olaf Scholz ist jetzt echt der Tiefpunkt.
Aber man denkt immer so, das wäre jetzt der Tiefpunkt. Und dann kommt halt noch einer.
Und dieser Merz, der eigentlich es nicht schafft, etwas auszudrücken,
ohne mindestens die absolute Mehrheit der Deutschen zu beschimpfen,
das ist,
katastrophal. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie dieser Mann mit diesem Gesicht und diesen
Äußerungen in irgendeiner Form eine Aufbruchstimmung oder eine positive Stimmung
in Land bringen kann, meint zu können.
Der kann doch noch nicht mal eine positive Stimmung in was weiß ich,
in Hochzeitstag mit seiner Frau bringen also das ist doch wirklich,
der Mann ist doch komplette Fehlbesetzung,
Ja.
Das ist leider so also ich meine vielleicht sollten wir mal hier so ein bisschen
ein paar Zahlen sagen, was da jetzt eigentlich passiert ist,
also was ja wirklich also dass die AfD,
43,8% vorläufiges Ergebnis steht hier, bekommen hat. Und damit sozusagen auch
ihren Wahler-Anteil um die Hälfte vergrößert hat. Also verdoppelt hat.
Das ist ja nur das eine. Das andere ist, dass die Wahlbeteiligung einen Rekordwert von 77,8% hatte.
Das heißt.
Da sind dann auch alle extra nochmal irgendwie aus der Scheune gekrochen gekommen,
um überhaupt mal zu wählen.
Also ein riesiger Nichtwähleranteil. Ich habe jetzt Wählerwanderungsanalysen,
nicht gesehen, aber so ist es dann halt dann doch.
Man denkt sich ja immer, hohe Wahlbeteiligung würde ja irgendwie dazu führen,
dass sich dann irgendwie auch was Demokratisches durchsetzt.
Aber offensichtlich ist einfach die Situation, ich hätte jetzt fast im Osten
gesagt, aber zumindest jetzt erstmal in Sachsen-Anhalt,
so deformiert, dass da einfach in den etablierten Parteien einfach für sie da
keinerlei Option mehr gesehen wird.
Und wenn man sich halt den Prozess unserer Politik so anschaut.
Kann man das irgendwie nachvollziehen weil,
es geht halt auch nichts voran das ist alles nur Gewäsch,
und Business as usual und keiner traut sich irgendwas,
nennenswertes mal anzugehen und wenn man halt März zuhört, wie er so Tag um
Tag dokumentiert, wie er einfach keinerlei Kontakt eigentlich zu der Realsituationen im Land hat,
dann muss man sich dann halt auch nicht mal groß wundern, weil das ist natürlich
dann immer die Stärke der Rechtspopulisten, in solchen Situationen daraus Kapital zu schlagen.
Und dann kann man natürlich tausendmal sagen, so ja, aber ihr wählt ja gegen
eure eigenen Interessen.
Ja, tun sie. Das ist das, was sie dann halt tun, weil es halt irgendwie,
ja, fast schon mehr so ein Hilfeschrei ist.
Ja, wir wählen jetzt einfach das, was am meisten Entsetzen bei euch auslöst.
Einfach nur deswegen.
Ähm,
Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass,
einfach nur deswegen, kann ich mir noch nicht mal vorstellen.
Ich glaube, der hat schon auch, also wenn du ihn mal angeguckt hast.
Nicht nur.
Genau. Was der für einen, der hat halt einen Wahlkampf gemacht,
wie ihn andere Parteien nicht mehr machen.
Der ist da mit der Schwalbe schön übers Land gefahren.
Der hat sich für die Menschen Zeit genommen, mit denen geredet,
die ernst genommen, ja, zum Beispiel findet man, also man,
also zumindest Deutsche oder nach seiner Auffassung Deutsche und sicherlich
nicht deren Mehrheit hat er beschimpft, macht er einfach nicht, ne,
also der hat halt seine eigene Wählerschaft nicht beschimpft.
Als faul oder sonst was. Ganz im Gegenteil. Er hat.
Sie halt in irgendeine Form von nie dagewesener Vergangenheit romantisiert und
was nicht alles. Und dann halt massiven, natürlich ganz klar gesehen,
ganz klar immer ein Bild davon, wer irgendwie schuld ist, aber er hat eine Aufbruchsstimmung versprüht.
Und ich glaube, dass sehr viel von der,
Magie, von der politischen Magie eben auch daherkommt, dass du die Leute mitnimmst. Dass du,
ja, dass Leute sagen, okay, krass, da ist jetzt, Obama hatte das ja,
ich glaube, in dem ersten Wahlkampf als Motto Change you can believe in.
Also wir glauben daran, dass sich hier etwas ändert. Und wenn du das,
also Also diese Aufbruchstimme oder irgend so ein Jo, geil, das bringt halt so ein März nicht mit.
Und die anderen Parteien auch immer, also auch wirklich, keine Ahnung,
ich kann jetzt auch keine Begeisterung dafür empfinden, wenn da irgendwie Lars
Klingbeil wieder irgendwie erzählt, warum alles nicht funktioniert und dass
das jetzt leider so ist oder so.
Und wenn dann einer mit der Simson angeknattert kommt und sagt,
pass auf, schmeißt ja alle Ausländer raus und dann geht das hier wieder ab.
So, dann sagen Leute, okay, gut. der ist nett, der redet mit mir und der hat
einen Plan, den ich verstehe.
Ja,
also da warte ich noch drauf, dass die Politik sich mal an die eigene Nase fasst,
aber ehrlich gesagt, ich habe jetzt kurz nochmal nachgeschaut und Friedrich
Merz ist immer noch Kanzler.
Das gibt es doch nicht.
Ja. und.
Aber wir haben jetzt ja gerade schon einen random Soundbite von diesem Mann
mal eingespielt, was der so dann von sich gibt, wenn man ihn mal reden lässt.
Wir haben auch, man erlobt ja zum Beispiel auch dann YouTuber,
die auf deren Wahlkampfveranstaltungen rumrennen und irgendwie beispielsweise,
Journalistinnen dann da ansprechen, irgendwie beleidigen,
filmen und deren Namen benennen.
Ein Beispiel von Ann-Kathrin Müller, die beim Spiegel sehr viel über die AfD
berichtet. Und das natürlich eben nach den journalistischen Standards des Spiegel.
Die, sagen wir mal, nicht immer
die, die, sagen wir mal, sich von den Titelbildern etwas unterscheiden.
Das mit dem der gefährlichste Mann Deutschlands oder was sie da jetzt hatten beim Spiegel.
Das war, glaube ich, ein Geschenk für den Sigmund. Das war wirklich ein Schuss in den Ofen, aber,
ihre Arbeit ist eben journalistischer Natur und dann musste sie sich da von
irgendeinem YouTuber da beschimpfen lassen und die Konsequenz davon ist natürlich,
dass diese Menschen dann,
eingeschüchtert werden, Droh-E-Mails und sonstigen Käse erhalten, weil es natürlich.
Dieses Einschüchtern und Niedermachen eben ein Teil der Taktik ist,
auch diese kritischen Stimmen eben zum Verstummen zu bringen.
Und ich bin an diesem Abend, kurz nach dem Wahlergebnis, das war wahrscheinlich
so eine Stunde danach, bin ich mit meinem Lastenrad durch Berlin-Marzahn gefahren.
Jetzt auch keine Hochburg der progressiven politischen Kräfte.
Und dann hielt so neben mir an der Ampel so eine so ein Shopper, so eine Harley,
und hatte hinten eine Fahne dran,
Und es war eine Pride-Flagge. Da ist dann halt so ein Motorradfahrer,
der sich dann diesen Moment ausgewählt hat, um,
in seiner Lederkluft mit diesem Shopper, hinten mit einer riesigen Pride-Flagge,
da durch die Abendsonne zu fahren und mal eben Flagge zu zeigen,
in einer solchen Situation, die sicherlich,
auf einige Menschen, die jetzt vielleicht,
andere Hintergründe haben als du und ich, sicherlich noch mal sehr viel mehr
zusetzt, was Zukunftssorge, individuelles, persönliches Bedrohungsgefühl angeht und so weiter.
Und das fand ich ein sehr schöner Moment in dieser Situation.
Und dann haben wir uns kurz gegrüßt und dann war auch schon wieder grün und,
der machte dann weiter seine Tour.
Und das sind natürlich jetzt schon sehr wichtige Aspekte.
Sich dann nicht zum Verstummen bringen zu lassen. Und ich bin dann so in mich
gegangen und habe so gedacht, ja, hör mal.
Warum hast du das jetzt eigentlich nicht? Warum hast du eigentlich nicht,
warum zeigst du nicht auf?
Warum trägst du das nicht offen zu jeder Zeit deine Positionierung, deine Stellung?
Ich habe jetzt eine Frisur, die das größtenteils vermuten lässt,
wie ich ungefähr politisch orientiert bin, aber ich.
Und mir ist dann auch nochmal klarer geworden, wie wichtig das ist,
eben in diesen Zeiten diese Sichtbarkeit zu bewahren und zu erhalten.
Dass das eben nicht wegdringt und dass die Leute nicht durch eine Straße gehen
und sagen, jo, alles klar, hier wählt die Hälfte AfD und das ist offenbar ganz normal.
Ja, weil jeder, der und als ich dann so überlegt habe, war mir auch klar,
ja, weil ich halt keinen Bock habe, dass irgendwann was weiß ich, meine,
ich an der falschen Straßenecke auf die Fresse kriege, was ja früher,
Gang und Gäbe war, dass ich wegrennen musste oder dass, was weiß ich, ein,
Gegenstand von mir zerstört wird oder das Haus,
beschmiert oder das Auto kaputtgekloppt oder was auch immer oder das Motorrad
umgedreht oder was auch immer man so machen kann.
Aber ich glaube, das war, insofern hat mich das halt auch so,
zum Nachdenken angerichtet, weil man eben jetzt Flagge zeigen muss und das war
ein sehr schöner Moment,
den dieser Mann mir da beschert hat und die hat da auch einen Prozess angeregt bei mir.
Ja, aber wer jetzt wirklich reagieren muss, ist halt einfach die bundesdeutsche,
Politik. Ich meine, jetzt sind wir in dieser absurden Situation.
Wir haben ja schon so oft über AfD-Verbot geredet.
Ja, aber der Zeitpunkt ist immer so ungünstig. Ja. Jetzt ist er auch gerade wieder ungünstig.
Vor der Wahl war der ungünstig, nach der Wahl ist er ungünstig.
Erst haben die zu wenig Prozente gehabt.
Und jetzt haben sie zu viel. Ja, kann man leider nichts machen.
Nee, ja. Ah, und das hilft auch nur der AfD.
Ja, und das sind so Leute, die dann also ganz gerne mal ihren Sonntagsreden,
aber auch von wehrhafter Demokratie reden.
Ja.
Ja, also davon sehe ich halt irgendwie relativ wenig und wenn die wehrhaft ist,
dann stimmt irgendwie nicht auf der Ebene. Also es ist alles sehr enttäuschend.
Und ja, jetzt sind wir aber in dieser Situation und müssen halt schauen,
wie wir das mitigiert bekommen. Die nächsten Wahlen werden jetzt sicherlich
nicht sehr viel besser laufen.
Berlin wird sich sicherlich ein bisschen anders eintunen, wird man sehen,
aber ehrlich gesagt, ich habe auch relativ wenig Hoffnung, dass in Berlin eine
Wahlkonstellation bei rauskommt, die in irgendeiner Form vorankommt.
Dafür ist es halt jetzt hier auch alles schon zu zerstreut und wenn die CDU
heute schon ankündigt, dass sie ja mit den Linken auf gar keinen Fall und die
SPD ja auch nicht und oh Gott und jetzt mit Enteignung und wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Ja, also wir machen vorher schon mal alles schön klar, dass sie später nicht
miteinander zusammenarbeiten können. Was ist denn das für eine Einstellung?
Also wirklich.
Ja, das ist wirklich zum Heulen.
Vor allem mit was für einer Massi, mit was für einer Vehemenz die CDU da die
ganze Zeit irgendwie sich von der Linken distanziert. Man würde sich ja wünschen,
das würde jemand mit der AfD machen.
Ja, nee, das geht ja nicht.
Nee, das ist eine demokratisch gewählte Partei.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht.
Wenn der Wähler will.
Diese Linkenphobie der Rechten, also der Konservativen,
ich verstehe die nicht. ich verstehe was regt die denn die ganze Zeit so unglaublich
auf ist das weil sie irgendwie den Kapitalismus kritisieren,
es scheint ja irgendwie so ein bisschen im Zentrum zu stehen dass man das ja
überhaupt in Frage stellen kann dieses Modell was nun nachweislich im Wesentlichen
dazu beiträgt diesen Planeten zu ruinieren,
wünschst du mir da ein bisschen mehr Flexibilität?
Ja, vor allem auch, weil, wenn du dir mal anschaust, wo hast du stabile und
zufriedene Gesellschaften?
Das hast du da, wo du,
Also ein starker Prädiktor von, da sind die Menschen zufrieden und das ist die
Gesellschaft stabil, ist, je kleiner,
die Spannbreite in der Durchschnittsbevölkerung ist, was das Vermögen angeht
oder quasi den Reichtum.
Also das heißt nicht, dass wenn alle gleich sind, sie am glücklichsten sind.
Aber das heißt vor allem, wenn das in den Gesellschaften, wo undurchdringbare.
Barrieren zwischen den sozialen Schichten sind oder so riesige Abstände dazwischen, Dass quasi das gesamte,
Wohlstands- und Zugehörigkeitsversprechen, das dir die Gesellschaft, die dich umgibt, bietet,
oder versucht zu machen, einfach lächerlich ist.
Weil du weißt, es gibt hier der gesellschaftliche Wohlstand oder die nächste
gesellschaftliche Stufe,
auf der ich eigentlich sein möchte, in Form der Teilhabe, die ist so unglaublich
überhaupt nicht erreichbar,
dass du dann eben sagst, alles klar, dann scheiß doch auf diese Gesellschaft,
warum soll ich die denn stabilisieren, wenn die mir als potenzielles Mitglied,
kein attraktives Angebot der Teilhabe macht?
Und dass das nicht passiert, das machen die linken Kräfte in einer Demokratie, die zusehen,
dass man dem Kapitalismus innewohnenden Umverteilung von unten nach oben eine
geringe Gegentendenz bietet.
Um langfristig eben auch dafür zu sorgen, dass genug Leute an der ganzen Scheiße noch mitmachen.
Und die dann über Jahrzehnte zu verteufeln und irgendwie als bläh, bläh, bläh, bläh,
dann führst du eben in diese Gesellschaft, wo wir wahrscheinlich den Kipppunkt jetzt,
sehr nahe haben und in Sachsen-Anhalt eben auch schon quasi erreicht haben,
dass die Leute sagen, ist uns kackegal.
Also Hauptsache nicht mehr diese Gesellschaft.
Naja, das ist halt, das müsste einfach eine Priorität sein, aber es wird irgendwie
offensichtlich nicht prioritätsmäßig behandelt.
Das ist das Dilemma. Da haben wir jetzt leider auch keinerlei andere Rezepte
im Angebot, mit denen wir das kommentieren können. Das ist halt einfach so.
Naja, aber wenn sie sich nicht darum kümmern, dann kümmern sie sich ja zumindest,
über die Sicherheit der IT-Infrastruktur.
Wenn man da schon so viel Zeit gewonnen hat.
Berlin wurde angegriffen.
Ja.
Wie heißt der?
Kai Wegner, der Tennisspieler da.
Künftiger, ehemaliger erster Bürgermeister.
Den werden wir einen Platz benennen in Berlin. Und den nennt man Tennisplatz.
Ja, wer den Witz nicht versteht, der Herr war ja, als hier irgendwie der Stromausfall war, durch,
den Sabotageakt auf so eine Kabel Führung auf einer Brücke.
Ja, da hat er dann gesagt, er kümmert sich jetzt irgendwie um alles,
aber er muss dann doch erstmal Tennis spielen gehen. Das hat er natürlich dann,
öffentlich erstmal versucht zu vertuschen. Das kam natürlich dann alles raus.
Seitdem ist sein Stern noch etwas mehr gesunken.
Weißt du, ich finde das ja noch nicht mal, also ich finde, also das ist so ein Klassiker, ne?
Der wurde halt gefragt, sagen Sie mal, haben Sie eigentlich den Vormittag gemacht?
Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, ich habe hier die ganze Zeit Krisenstab mit alle
telefoniert, ich habe hier kein Auge zu getan.
Und dann haben sie halt gesagt, achso, weil wir haben eigentlich gedacht,
sie waren den ganzen Vormittag Tennis spielen und haben sich um nichts geschissen.
Und dann, ja, nee, doch, ich habe ja nach dem Tennis telefoniert oder so.
Und das war dann einfach, ja, hat sich dann halt in so ein Lügenkorsett da begeben.
Gut, habe ich jetzt kein Mitleid mit, weil der...
Ich hatte jetzt auch nicht den Eindruck, dass meine Stadt hier bei dem in einer guten Hand war.
Ja, aber es ist auch wieder so ein schönes, mein Gott, dann hat er halt Tennis gespielt, who cares.
Am Ende ist er ja nicht unbedingt derjenige, der jetzt hier irgendwie an den
Sachen wirklich dran ist.
Aber dieses mangelnde Fallengefühl und dann eben auch noch so diese Peinlichkeit,
das dann auch noch zu vertuschen,
das zeigt halt einfach, dass der Mensch nicht aus dem richtigen Stoff gemacht
ist für diese Stadt also der auch wirklich,
diese Vielfalt und die Dynamik der Stadt die Berlin ja nun mal hat einfach so,
null repräsentiert, also in gar keiner Form.
Das macht ja die ganze Berliner CDU nicht, wir haben ja glaube ich vor zwei
Sendungen schon darüber gesprochen, was die hier tapezieren an Plakaten Jetzt
rege ich mich wieder über diesen Wahlkampf auf.
Die diskutieren hier die Poller.
Ja, aber es ist genau das Ding wie mit Merz, wo wir schon gesprochen haben.
Es ist halt einfach so, ja, wir sind für die Parkplätze Autofahrer und den Grünewald
zuständig und der Rest interessiert uns einen Scheißdreck. Das ist sozusagen
das, was davon ausgegangen ist.
Leider war ja nun von dem Stromausfall auch der Westen betroffen im Wesentlichen.
Deswegen kam das halt mal nicht so gut an, weil man sich nicht mal um den Grunewald kümmern kann.
Dann wird es halt wirklich ein Problem. Wäre das jetzt im Osten gewesen?
Naja, im Osten ist ja eh alles kaputt.
Das hätte er wahrscheinlich noch überlebt. Aber dann jetzt noch einen Stromausfall,
im tiefen Westen zu ignorieren, das war dann halt doch zu viel.
Das war zu viel.
Naja, gut. Auf jeden Fall, wir wollen ja eigentlich auf was anderes hinaus.
Genau, jetzt haben wir... Also, was ist passiert? die das Verwaltungsnetz,
Der, ja, also der,
das Bundes-, der Stadt Berlin wurde gehackt, wurde infiltriert von einer Ransomware-Gruppe
mit den Namen, ich weiß nicht, wie sie sich aussprechen, man kommuniziert mit
denen üblicherweise über Chat-Nachrichten,
Rysida, Rysida, keine Ahnung, Rysida sage ich jetzt, ja, R-H-Y-S-I-D-A.
Und was macht diese Gruppe?
Die infiltrieren Organisationen,
und machen genau das, was ich hier auch in dem Vortrag mit Kai Biermann hier
in der Hacken Hackback Edition behandelt hatte.
Ransomware-Gruppe, also die verschlüsseln Systeme und exfiltrieren Daten und
drohen mit der Veröffentlichung der Daten. In diesem Fall,
sind das relativ viele Daten, die wurden jetzt auch veröffentlicht,
so viel sei gespoilert, 5,8 Terabyte haben sie dann exfiltriert und hatten von
Berlin ungefähr 2 Millionen Euro in Bitcoin gefordert,
um diese, im Gegenzug diese Veröffentlichung nicht durchzuführen.
Vielleicht mal so ein bisschen, ich bin ja, also das ist ja mein Job,
mich mit solchen Sachen zu beschäftigen.
Und es ist sehr bitter, dass quasi diese Ransomware-Gruppen,
die machen das jetzt seit ungefähr
zehn Jahren ist das ein relativ großes Geschäft, genau das zu machen.
Es ging los mit so locky, einfachen, im Prinzip simplen Kryptotrojanern, die.
Einfach nur alle Dateien auf der Festplatte verschlüsseln und dann halt irgendwie
so Forderungen im Bereich 500 bis 1000 US-Dollar gestellt haben für den Key,
diese Dateien wieder herzustellen.
Das ist so ein bisschen B2C-Model. Also da ist deine Zielgruppe,
Einzelpersonen, irgendwelche
Eltern, die jetzt gerade mal die ersten zwei Jahre ihres Neugeborenen in Fotos
verloren haben oder so und die erpresst du um eine Summe, die sie schon irgendwie
mobilisieren können und so weiter.
Und dann hat sich das relativ zeitnah so weiterentwickelt, wo man halt festgestellt
hat, naja, okay, wenn wir so einen Trojaner in ein Unternehmensnetz bringen, also vom B2C zu B2B,
dann können wir natürlich auch ganz andere Summen befordern.
Und wenn wir dann nicht nur einen Rechner übernehmen, weil da ist natürlich
üblicherweise ein Unternehmen gut aufgestellt, also einen Rechner können die
in der Regel verschmerzen, weil
sie ja eine zentralisierte Infrastruktur betreiben mit einem File-Share,
wo die Musik spielt oder vielleicht auch ein Backup oder vor allem einem Active
Directory, was die ganze Flotte verwaltet oder vielleicht sogar noch eine Reihe
an internen Services, wo wir gar nicht mehr.
Sag ich mal, die Dateien hostage nehmen, sondern die Funktionalität,
die Betriebsbereitschaft dieser Infrastruktur.
Und da kann man natürlich dann sehr viel höhere Forderungen stellen.
Eben nicht nur, was weiß ich, vielleicht mal 500 oder 1.000,
vielleicht auch mal 2.000, sondern hier wie im Fall von Berlin 2 Millionen.
Und ich habe in meiner beruflichen Tätigkeit schon auch sehr viel höhere Forderungen gesehen.
Und dann haben sie irgendwann gesagt.
So festgestellt, dass die Unternehmen immer seltener zahlen,
weil sie dann vielleicht doch in der Lage sind, ihre Betriebsbereitschaft wieder herzustellen.
Vielleicht kurz noch als Punkt, wenn das Unternehmen nicht funktioniert,
verliert es Geld und zwar sehr viel pro Tag, die Sachen nicht laufen.
Und der Wiederanlauf nimmt dann Zeit ein. Das heißt, da kann man sehr schnell
sagen, hier, wir haben unmittelbare Abhilfe durch den Schlüssel, kostet halt jetzt.
Deswegen kommen dann viele Unternehmen in die,
in die Verlegenheit die Zahlung in Betracht zu ziehen oder eben auch zu tätigen.
Aber das hat ein bisschen nachgelassen. Da haben sie irgendwann gesagt,
naja, okay, wir haben ja außerdem noch hier Daten von den Unternehmen.
Die merken auch nicht, wenn wir die exfiltrieren. Also drohen wir doch auch
mal gleichzeitig mit der Veröffentlichung.
Das ist ein relativ wichtiger Punkt, dass man diesen Unterschied versteht.
Dieses Verschlüsseln bei einem Unternehmen oder bei einer Organisation in der
Regel eben Betriebsbereitschaft.
Da geht es also, ja, Sachen sind verschlüsselt, aber das konzentriert sich weniger
darauf, dass es jetzt die Dateien sind, sondern dass es die Systeme sind.
Und das drohen mit der Veröffentlichung von Daten, eben Anprangern,
potenzielle Drittschäden, die damit einhergehen, sensible Daten,
die veröffentlicht werden.
Was, je nachdem wen du angegriffen hast natürlich ein,
unterschiedliches Potenzial hat also was weiß ich, einige also jedes Unternehmen
will in der Regel nicht seine Dateien veröffentlicht haben aber weiß ich nicht, wenn jetzt,
keine Ahnung, nimmst du eine Arztpraxis oder so da hast du natürlich ein ganz
anderes Potenzial an, wenn die jetzt da zum Beispiel Patientendaten oder sowas veröffentlichen,
und so balancieren die Angreifergruppen eben diese beiden Droh-Szenarien kombinieren, die einfach in eins und
so macht das dann eben Sinn, dass sie sagen, okay, ach so, die Betriebsunterbrechung
tut dir nicht so weh, naja, was hältst du denn davon, wenn wir jetzt mal hier
einfach alle diese Daten veröffentlichen, was im Fall von Berlin dann irgendwie Informationen über,
Wasserversorgung, allerhand Personen, personalinterne Sachen und was nicht alles,
ich habe das noch gar nicht alles durchlesen können,
sind. So, wie haben sie es gemacht?
Und üblicherweise willst du als Angreifer eine Schadsoftware,
auf einen Rechner bekommen, der in das interne Netz angeboten ist.
Und was sie hier machen, ist eine relativ interessante Social Engineering,
das seit einiger Zeit, also Anfang 26 von Microsoft schon beschrieben wurde,
ClickFix, wo sie Leute trickreich dazu bringen, das Windows Terminal zu öffnen
und da drin ein PowerShell-Skript auszuführen.
Und das tun sie, indem sie sich als ein Capture tarnen und dann sagen,
ja, wir sind jetzt ein Capture, um weiterzumachen, musst du jetzt hier Windows
X und dann Windows I und dann Windows Control V und dann Enter drücken.
So, was bedeutet mit, ich glaube mit Windows X machst du halt das Terminal auf,
mit Windows I machst du PowerShell,
und dann mit Steuerung V machst du, pastest du halt ein PowerShell-Skript,
was dir die Webseite vorher per JavaScript.
In deine Zwischenablage reingetauen hat. Weil du kannst eben mit JavaScript,
oder ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das JavaScript direkt das da reinkopiert oder,
ich glaube, das geht, ansonsten,
schreiben sie es halt in ein Feld, was du nicht siehst, was markiert ist,
wenn du Steuerung C drückst oder so.
Aber ich meine eigentlich zumindest früher, als ich noch solche Scherzchen gemacht
habe, konntest du einfach auch so per JavaScript da reinschreiben. Und,
Das heißt, die Nutzerin oder der Nutzer denkt, dass sie ja gerade einen Capture
lösen und dass das irgendwie komische Verrenkungen mit drück mal Windows X.
Ein Hergeld ist jetzt noch nicht mal mehr überraschend.
So kann man richtig beweisen, dass man ein Mensch ist, indem man sich von der
Maschine zu vollkommen dusseligen Tätigkeiten anstiften lässt.
Und dann dieses PowerShell-Skript ist letztendlich ein Herunterladen der richtigen
Malware und dann direktes Ausführen.
Und gleichzeitig wird dann die Webseite, die manipulierte Webseite,
bleibt im Vordergrund und,
fordert dich zu weiteren Aktionen auf, damit du abgelenkt bist und nicht siehst,
dass eben in diesem PowerShell-Fenster Dinge passieren.
Und dann haben sie hier in diesem, das ist ja noch detaillierter analysiert,
wo dann irgendwie eine Windows-Exe hast, wo eine DLL daneben gelegt wird,
die dann über Side-Loading geladen wird, damit eine MyWare ist.
Ich glaube, das geht jetzt zu sehr ins Detail. Aber so hast du quasi dann den initialen Vektor.
Und meistens ist das dann eine letztendlich so ein Remote-Access-Control-Toolkit,
also ein Trojaner, über den die Angreifer dann sagen, okay, jetzt schauen wir
uns mal hier um auf dem Rechner, schauen wir uns mal um im Netzwerk.
Ja, und was sie da dann vorgefunden haben, war dann, dass sie relativ schnell,
Dateien mit Passwörtern in Plaintext finden.
Andere Pfade, die du dann gehst, ist, du willst ja quasi von diesem einen Rechner,
den du da jetzt hast, auf, du willst eigentlich die ganze Flotte übernehmen.
Dein Ziel ist, die Backups zu zerstören.
Dein Ziel ist, potenziell die administrative Kontrolle über die Serverlandschaft
zu bekommen oder über das gesamte Environment.
Und den meisten derartiger Netzwerke wird dazu eben Microsoft Active Directory genutzt.
Das ist also im weitesten Sinne so ein flotten Management-System,
kann man sich vorstellen.
Wenn du jetzt ein Unternehmen bist mit, keine Ahnung, zehn, hundert oder tausenden
Rechnern, dann willst du ja nicht Turnschuh-Administration betreiben,
wo du zu jedem einzelnen Rechner gehst, sondern du willst quasi Konfigurationsänderungen
an einer zentralen Stelle machen.
Und dafür ist Microsoft Active Directory eben das zur Verfügung stehende Tool, um das zu tun.
Deswegen meldet man sich eben in den Unternehmensnetzwerken in der Regel nicht
an dem lokalen Rechner an, sondern an der Domäne.
Ja, weil die Domäne eben der zentrale Punkt ist, der sagt, du bist ein User
in dieser Firma oder nicht.
Und das hat eine ganze Reihe an unglaublichen Vorteilen, so ein System.
Aber ist eben auch ein zentraler Angriffspunkt und ist leider aufgrund seiner
Komplexität relativ schwierig abzudichten.
Deswegen findest du in der Regel irgendeinen Weg auf Tausenden,
manche sehr einfache, manche etwas kompliziertere Wege, Administrationsrechte
in diesem Active Directory zu bekommen und dann gehört dir eben die ganze Flotte.
Dann kannst du halt den daran anhängenden Servern zum Beispiel sagen,
verschlüsselt mal bitte,
die Festplatten der virtuellen Server, die da liegen oder rollt doch mal bitte
diesen Trojaner aus oder richtet doch mal hier noch einen Nutzeraccount ein,
damit ich einfacher die Daten runterladen kann und so weiter und so fort. Und.
Es ist ja jetzt etwas, was mich halt auch, dadurch, dass ich mich da sehr viel
immer mit auseinandersetze, immer in so vielen Schadenfällen
das Gleiche sehe oder in so vielen Red Teams in unterschiedlichen Organisationen
die gleichen Fehler sehe, ist es halt wirklich auf eine Weise faszinierend,
dass diese Angreifergruppen letztendlich so,
ja, man könnte fast sagen, One-Trick-Ponys sind. Die kennen bestimmte Wege,
die sie gehen. Und die funktionieren einfach auch.
Als Conti sich zerlegt hat, weil Russland die Ukraine angegriffen hat und dadurch
die Mitglieder von Conti auf einmal,
starke Ansichten hatten,
was diese Situation anging und sich die ukrainischen Mitglieder und die russischen
Mitglieder nicht mehr, die konnten einfach keine Arbeitsebene mehr.
Und dann wurden halt auch so Manuale geleakt, wo du dann wirklich so,
weißt du, wie du dir das so vorstellst und jetzt klicke darauf und jetzt klicke
darauf, weil es so verhältnismäßig immer gleich ist, dass du das eben überall machen kannst.
Und was mich natürlich schon auch sehr fasziniert ist, dass wir nicht daraus lernen,
als ITler, als Organisationen, als Unternehmen oder Sonstiges und ich habe lange
darüber nachgedacht, warum das so ist und meine Erklärung ist eigentlich,
dass diese ganzen IT-Sachen eben nicht,
für die Menschen gemacht sind.
Also die ITler bauen die pflegen halt eine IT, aber die wissen ja gar nicht,
oder die versuchen natürlich auch aus gutem Grund sich nicht damit auseinanderzusetzen,
was die Menschen mit dieser IT machen.
Welche Prozesse sich darauf abbilden. Weißt du? Die sagen dann,
nee, nee, hier nicht auf Link klicken, nicht auf Link klicken.
Haben aber natürlich eine Infrastruktur dahin gebaut, die letztendlich abschmiert,
wenn einer auf Link klickt.
Statt sich, und wollen lieber natürlich gar nicht wissen, was die anderen Menschen,
die arbeiten mit dieser IT machen.
Und deswegen leben wir halt an so vielen Stellen in einer Welt,
wo die Menschen unzufrieden sind mit der IT, die IT-Systeme.
Vielleicht sicher ist, aber eben nicht gegen die Angriffsszenarien,
die sie tatsächlich zu erwarten hat.
Weil die Prozesse, die sich darauf abbilden, eben auch nicht geeignet sind für
das, was die Menschen eigentlich erreichen wollen.
Einige erinnern sich sicherlich an meine kleine Einlassung vor einiger Zeit,
als es um KI ging, wo ich gesagt habe, keiner wollte jemals ein Programm oder
ein Tool haben. Die Leute wollen eine Lösung haben.
Und alles, was wir denen hinstellen, sind irgendwelche komplexen,
historisch gewachsenen Scheiß-Interfaces.
Und dann kommt einer und sagt, hier nicht drücken, hier nicht drücken.
Nee, das darfst du nicht.
Und das ist, glaube ich, mein aktueller Erklärungsansatz dafür,
warum das in so gut wie jeder Organisation ab einer gewissen Größe so einfach funktioniert.
Weil wir das nicht holistisch und vernünftig zusammendenken.
Das war jetzt so ein bisschen der philosophische Gedanke.
Das grundlegende Problem bleibt eine Komplexität und diese Komplexität kriegst
du nicht gemeistert und nicht abgesichert, wenn du nicht verstehst,
was die Menschen damit machen.
Weil wenn du sagst, du machst hier Checklisten-Security, dann heißt das nicht,
dass du dich gezielt auf das Angriffsszenario, was dir blüht,
konzentrierst und das priorisierst.
Zum Beispiel, einer unserer Clients ist infiziert und fängt auf einmal an,
im internen Netz zu hacken.
Wenn man weiß, dass das, wenn man auf dem Schirm hat, dass das ein Szenario
ist, gegen das man sich schützen muss, dann könnte man so einfache Dinge machen,
wie, hör mal, sobald ein Terabyte von uns ins Internet geschickt wurde,
gucken wir mal, was da los ist.
Um nicht irgendwie fünf Wochen später zu sagen, scheiße, jetzt haben wir es veröffentlicht.
Das sind so einfache Dinge, die könnte man in den letzten Jahren mal gelernt haben.
Klar, da musst du aber verstehen, wenn du jetzt, wenn du sagst,
ich ziehe eine arbitriere Grenze, wie viele Daten jemand zugreifen darf,
dann kann es eben sein, dass du bestimmte Prozesse störst. Deswegen brauchst
du Kenntnis von den Prozessen, um zu sagen, alles klar, der darf das,
der darf das nicht, wir cashen, wie auch immer.
Aber du musst halt verstehen, was da abgeht. Und der Case, der Fileserver oder
ein User schickt auf einmal 5,8 Terabyte irgendwo hin,
der sollte irgendwo so eine kleine, sollte man sagen, da haben wir so eine kleine
da haben wir so eine Detection, das würden wir dann wohl zumindest nach einem Terabyte mehr.
Ja, und diese.
Ja, haben wir nicht gemacht. Jetzt ist es natürlich immer sehr einfach,
dann auf die IT einzuschlagen, sagen, warum habt ihr nicht alles richtig gemacht.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, wie das jetzt hier gelaufen ist.
Ich habe jetzt verschiedene Sachen gehört, deswegen kann ich jetzt auch kein
Fingerpointing machen, aber es kann natürlich auch sehr gut sein.
Also das ist, sagen wir mal, zumindest im Gerüchtekanal. Und von daher sage
ich, kann sein, dass das auch so war,
dass Vorschläge zur Verbesserung dieser ganzen Anmeldesituation und so weiter,
gemacht wurden, aber dafür halt dann keine Genehmigungen beziehungsweise Gelder
freigemacht wurden oder keine entsprechenden kompetenten Personen reingeholt, angestellt,
wurden, andere Maßnahmen nicht zugelassen wurden, um das zu machen,
was ich auch für extrem plausibel halte.
Absolut. Also ich kann dir das in so gut wie jeder Krisensituation, in der ich,
beinwohnen durfte, hast du immer jemanden von IT oder IT-Sicherheit,
die sagen, ich habe vor 20 Jahren gesagt, wir sollen das machen.
Und ich habe immer gesagt, das ist das Risiko, was wir hier eingehen und nie
hat jemand hingehört. Das stimmt schon, natürlich.
Also ohne Frage. Aber du hast gerade einen sehr wichtigen Satz gesagt mit dem alles richtig machen.
Und du kannst halt nicht alles richtig machen. Deswegen musst du ja deine Verteidigung
und dein Schutzkonzept priorisieren nach, was sind die Angriffsflächen,
die wir haben, wie können wir die reduzieren?
Was sind die Schadenspotenziale, die wir haben?
Wie können wir die reduzieren? Und was sind die Wege, wie Angreifer uns angreifen?
Wie können wir das gezielt das verhindern?
Weil du kannst nicht alles richtig machen. Und das ist genau diese Checklisten-Security, die.
Da habe ich ja letztes Jahr bei der Blackhead auch einen Vortrag darüber gehalten.
Die ist der Grund, warum das alles so unsicher ist.
Weil es gibt ja hunderttausend Standards und Checklisten und Zertifikat.
Und hast du denn hier und das musst du noch machen und so weiter.
Und das ist wie so ein Steuersystem, wo du versuchst, gesunden Menschenverstand
in formale Regeln zu gießen. Und das geht halt nicht.
Es gelingt nicht. Je mehr Regeln du schreibst, desto absurder wird das ganze
Konstrukt. Und in dieser IT-Security-Regulierung kommen immer nur neue dazu.
Und dann sitzen Leute da und müssen blind irgendwelche beschissenen Regeln umsetzen,
statt zu sagen, alles klar, was will der Angreifer?
Und was machen wir hier? Was müssen wir können? Welche Rechte müssen wir,
welche Möglichkeiten müssen wir haben? Und wie können wir das,
was wir hier versuchen, sicher abbilden?
Und das ist ganz offensichtlich in Berlin dann nicht geschehen.
Wahrscheinlich, weil die alle mit irgendeinem anderen Scheiß beschäftigt waren.
Sicherlich auch, weil dafür kein Geld locker gemacht wurde. Ja.
Und da gibt es immer irgendeine Erklärung, aber das Phänomen bleibt halt,
jetzt haben wir den Salat.
Und dann kommen natürlich noch diese Sachen hinzu, ja eine Investition in die
Sicherheit ist ja eine Kostenstelle und wenn die Sicherheit gut ist,
dann merkt das niemand, dann fangen die Leute an und sagen, jetzt wollen wir
mal sparen, warum geben wir so viel Geld für Sicherheit aus, ist doch alles sicher.
Also diese ganzen Sachen hast du auch noch. Aber es bleibt natürlich schon einfach,
ein Grundproblem, dass so häufig Leute sagen, Sicherheit muss unbequem sein oder sowas.
Oder Sicherheit eben, wenn du sagst, hier wir machen das sicherer,
denken alle Leute sofort daran, ach scheiße, das wird jetzt kompliziert.
Da muss ich jetzt wieder irgendwas klicken oder das stört oder jetzt kann ich
keine E-Mail mehr schicken oder so.
Und ich bin eigentlich inzwischen durch die vielen Dinge, die ich gesehen habe,
eher davon überzeugt, dass,
der gezielte Prozess ist derjenige, der sich auch sichern lässt,
ohne behindernd zu sein.
Hören wir doch mal rein, was die Leiterin des IT-Dienstleistungszentrums Berlin
so zu den ergriffenen Maßnahmen für uns zu sagen hat.
Tun. Und da sind wir in Austausch mit dem entsprechenden Fahrverfahren verantwortlich
und auch mit der EKD-Sicherheit, wie man da ja zweiter vorgeht.
Ja gut, das wäre Case in Point. Das hätte jetzt in so einer Checklist-Security
schon drin gestanden, dass man keine hard-coded Credentials hat und dass man
die vielleicht auch ändern kann. 17 Stück oder was?
21, glaube ich, war die Zahl. Ja, also wer es nicht verstanden hat,
es gibt Projekterprogramme, wo die Passwörter im Quellcode abgelegt sind.
Das ist, sagen wir mal jetzt...
Das ist Breitband-Migräne.
Da sollte man gar keine Checkliste mehr für brauchen. Also sowas macht man einfach nicht.
Passwörter an sich gehören abgeschafft. Ja, das ist einfach eine Technologie.
Hier und da und als Last Resort und so weiter nochmal so ein Ding in der Schublade
haben, wenn was anderes nicht funktioniert, okay.
Aber so im täglichen Gebrauch irgendwas einzugeben, schon schwierig.
Dafür gibt es Public-Private-Key-Verfahren, da gibt es Chips,
die man irgendwo drauflegen kann, Karten, alles mögliche, Hardware-Geräte.
So wie man einen Schlüssel in der Tasche hat, um eine Tür zu öffnen in dieser
Behörde, könnte man auch einen Schlüssel in der Tasche haben,
um eine Datei zu öffnen in der Behörde.
Passwörter, naja, werden vergessen.
Passwort ist schon eh scheiße, aber hartgecodet? Junge!
Ja, aber dass dann in, und weil das dann so mühsam ist, dass dann in ein Programm
fest in den Quellcode, also wirklich in den ausgeführten Code fest einzubauen,
das ist ja quasi äquivalent zu gar keinen Schutz.
Das geht halt einfach mal überhaupt nicht. Und dass das vielleicht mal hier
irgendwo da und da und da passiert, aber 21 ist schon eine Zahl,
die selbst bei der Größe der IT des Landes Berlin insgesamt zu hoch ist.
Da muss man sich auch fragen, mit welchen Softwareherstellern arbeitet man denn
da zusammen, die sowas auch für richtig halten? Gibt es da nicht irgendwie was,
gibt es da keine Strafen für?
Also das wäre, also das ist jetzt wirklich, das ist so...
Atta, Atta ist das einzige Wort, was mir dazu einfällt. Da fallen mir nur noch englische Worte an.
Atta?
Im Sinne von Atta Madness oder was?
Ja, oder...
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Es ist einfach unglaubliche Verantwortungslosigkeit. Also eine,
vollständige, ein Überfluss an absoluter,
Wahnsinnsverantwortungslosigkeit. Das ist glaube ich das, was das ist.
Ja, genau.
Und aber ich bin mir ganz sicher, dass du, wenn du jetzt in die Dokumentation
von diesen Projekten gehst, Dann sagt dann auch jemand, hier,
ich hatte gedacht, das wäre vielleicht in Ordnung, wenn man das Passwort ändern könnte, aber dann,
hat der Softwareanbieter, der die Ausschreibung gewonnen hat,
gesagt, dass das extra kostet und dass wir ja eh schon irgendwie übers Budget
sind oder irgend so was wird da wieder stehen.
Oder der Softwareanbieter hat gesagt, also das machen wir eigentlich sehr ungern
mit dem Hardcoded Credential.
Und dann sagt der Land-Berliner Wieso. Auf der anderen Seite ist das Credential auch Hardcoded.
Wenn wir das jetzt bei euch ändern, dann müssen wir da, also da wirst du wieder
irgendwelche Wahnsinns.
Du erinnerst dich an das Gespräch mit der Bianca Kastel über Gesundheitsakte,
wo sie dann auch nochmal erklärt hat, wie das historisch zustande kam,
dass man auf die Patientenakten zugreifen kann, ohne jegliche,
ohne jegliches Passwort.
Wo auch irgendwann mal sich, da findest du auch irgendwo in den Dokumenten,
wo mal jemand sagt, das macht man eigentlich so nicht.
Das,
ist halt,
Ich frage mich halt auch,
warum,
wo ist eigentlich Deutschland falsch abgebogen?
Was verhindert über Jahrzehnte die Bereitschaft, sich mit diesen Sachen mal vertraut zu machen?
Also kleiner Trost, Tim, in
Deutschland ist es besonders schlimm und passt auch so gut zu Deutschland.
Ich würde aber nicht sagen, dass das jetzt notwendigerweise in anderen Ländern ist,
um Größenordnungen besser ist.
Aber du hast natürlich recht, dass ich glaube tatsächlich, dass es eine,
schon so eine Deutschland-Mentalität ist.
Ich glaube, das habe ich auch schon mal hier so ausgeführt, dass Deutsche immer
denken, dass Sachen irgendwann fertig sind.
Die bauen, weißt du,
ich finde, das kann man so ganz gut mit dem,
man denkt immer, dass man Sachen vervollkommenen kann. Und dass das dann irgendwann,
haben wir eine Software und die ist jetzt fertig.
Und das entwickelt sich auch nicht mehr weiter. Jetzt haben wir eine Maschine
gebaut und das ist eine deutsche Maschine und die läuft jetzt 30 Jahre so.
35. Wie der Diesel.
30 Jahre laufen die ja dann teilweise auch.
Ja, genau. Und das ist auch so, weil das sind Deutsche und die halten das Ding
am Laufen. Das ist die AS400, das ist der 486.
Den Code hat der Dieter geschrieben. Und der Dieter, das ist der Einzige,
der weiß, das ist super, die Maschine der hat uns nie im Stich gelassen.
Und wenn wir da jetzt was dran machen müssen, dann müssen wir den Dieter,
wenn der einen guten Moment hat, der ist jetzt leider schon im Heim,
aber wenn der einen guten Moment hat, dann kann man den noch was dazu fragen.
Der hat das nicht dokumentiert. Der Dieter, das war ein Genie.
Der hat das so geschrieben. Und in Assembler hat er das geschrieben.
Oder in Pascal, Turbo Pascal. Das ist ein Gedicht, dieses Software.
Ein Gedicht, wir verstehen es nur nicht.
Da hat noch keiner verstanden, was der Dieter gemacht hat. So genial ist das.
Und der Dieter hat dann ein ganz tolles Passwort hartgecodet.
Das weiß er jetzt leider nicht mehr. Wir haben auch schon mit der Enkelin telefoniert,
ob sie den noch mal geschäftsfähig spritzen können, ob der sich dann vielleicht
daran erinnert oder so weiter.
Das ist der Deutsche. Der denkt dann, das ist fertig.
Ja, aber auch selbst wenn er das,
Brücken stürzen auch irgendwann ein. Das hatten wir jetzt gerade in Berlin auch
ziemlich häufig, gerade in den letzten Monaten, wo dann für teuer Geld sehr
schnell mal was gebaut werden muss, damit die Autos wieder fahren können.
Wenn du als Brückenbauer dem Land Berlin ein Angebot machst und sagst,
pass auf, falls die einschutzgefährdet ist, hätte ich eine Lösung.
Dann würden die sagen, wir wollen keine einschutzgefährdete Brücke,
wir wollen eine fertige Brücke. Weißt du?
Und dann,
Ja, aber das Wasser tropft halt auch durch die IT-Systeme. Auch da gibt es Kalkablagerungen
und irgendwann ist das einfach alles nicht mehr richtig.
Worauf du hinaus willst ist, die Dinge sind nie fertig. Es ist,
wie sagt man so schön, Sicherheit ist kein Zustand, Sicherheit ist ein Prozess.
Exakt. Und dieser Prozess lässt sich eben, das war so ein bisschen das,
worauf ich eingangs hinaus wollte, dieser Sicherheitsprozess,
den kannst du ja nicht getrennt von den ganzen in anderen Prozessen sehen,
die halt mit dieser IT stattfinden sollen.
Aber okay, wir werden zu philosophisch. Ja, okay, so Berlin,
scheiße, kacke, 5,8 Terabyte, dann wurde auch eben wild diskutiert,
okay, zahlt man jetzt dieses Lösegeld?
Interessante Frage.
Hier nochmal aus besonderen Aspekten. Erstens, wenn die das Lösegeld bezahlt
hätten, wäre das Steuergeld gewesen.
Gut, wäre jetzt nicht die erste Scheiße, wofür sie Steuergeld ausgeben.
Wäre aber wahrscheinlich einer der wenigen Fälle, wo sie das direkt in die organisierte
Kriminalität geben. Das machen sie meistens nur über Umwege.
Aber die die,
Man muss sich jetzt mal sehen, ob mit dieser Veröffentlichung ein Schaden von
mehr als zwei Millionen einhergeht.
Das ist ja die ökonomische Betrachtung, die dann da viele Organisationen an der Stelle haben.
Wir nennen das ja, jetzt hätte ich es mich fast verfehlt also man kann da,
wir nennen das so ein bisschen die Cowboy-Mentalität, ne wenn Leute sagen, okay.
Wir zahlen unter keinen Umständen Lösegeld, ne und die meisten,
oder ich kenne Fälle von Leuten die dann, die stehen dann da und sagen,
ich werde niemals den Kriminellen das Geld geben, ne und dann sehen sie auf
einmal so, okay, in welchen,
auf welchen Schaden sie blicken und dass sie dann doch unter Umständen sehen,
naja, okay, scheiße, die haben mich halt an der Hammelbeine und wohl oder übel
muss ich jetzt hier in eine Verhandlung gehen und versuchen, noch,
schlimmeren Schaden abzuwenden.
Das Schadensausmaß durch diese Veröffentlichung wird ja jetzt,
glaube ich, so ein bisschen gerade erst durch die Journalistinnen und interessierten Bürgerinnen.
Er gründet, ja, was,
und Sascha Lobo hat ja, glaube ich, ich habe es noch nicht gelesen,
ich habe nur die Überschrift gelesen, dass er sagt, naja, was jetzt dieses Wissen,
und das war, das ist ein bisschen ein Aspekt, der sich jetzt in den letzten
Jahren geändert hat, ja, weißt du, diese Veröffentlichung,
die Veröffentlichung von Daten,
das von, was weiß ich, irgendwelchen Unternehmen oder so, wo du, das war,
tatsächlich, und da bin ich jetzt auch, da trenne ich meine persönliche Werthaltung
von dem, was man eben, wenn man da jetzt ökonomisch draufblickt,
der Schaden dadurch ist häufig einfach nicht vorhanden.
Es gibt einfach keinen Schaden durch diese Veröffentlichung.
Wenn du dir anschaust, Kai und ich hatten das auch in unserem Vortrag,
dieser Motel One Typ, Motel One ist das ja auch passiert, alle Motel One Kundendaten,
zack, im Internet veröffentlicht.
Alles, was der dazu kommentiert hat, war, leider hat es der Staat noch nicht
geschafft, seiner souveränen Aufgabe nachzukommen und Bürgerinnen und Unternehmen,
vor Cyber zu schützen. Wo du denkst, Junge, du bist Milliardär.
Mit unseren Daten, musst du selber schützen, nicht der Vater Staat.
Vater Staat hat ja auch schon die Corona-Hilfen irgendwie 100 Millionen von
bekommen. Was soll der Staat denn noch alles für den tun?
Auf der anderen Seite steht eben.
Und wahrscheinlich ist durch die gesamte Veröffentlichung kein monetärer Schaden
entstanden, der die Zahlung aufgewogen hätte.
Erst recht nicht für Motel One, weil für die ist ja gar kein Schaden entstanden.
Durch die Veröffentlichung jetzt, also sonst natürlich schon.
Aber kein Schaden, den sie jetzt abwenden konnten, mussten oder sollten.
Dann kann man Vater Staat die Schuld geben.
Insofern ist häufig der Schaden durch Veröffentlichung eben nicht so groß,
hier ist es potenziell anders weil eben,
eine Reihe an internen Informationen da betroffen sind, die jetzt jetzt müssen
sie 21 hartgecodete Passwörter ändern, überleg mal wie teuer das ist,
das hätten sich die Dienstleister ja auch alles bezahlt lassen,
wahrscheinlich hättest du damit schon die 2 Millionen am Ende gespart,
ja wahrscheinlich Ja klar, meinst du, die schenken dir das jetzt?
Okay, aber ich bin schon wieder zynisch.
Was sich geändert hat, ist,
dass du jetzt eben auch diese massenhaften Daten mit KIs scannen kannst.
Und dieses, oh, guck mal, da sind 5,8 Terabyte, Ja gut, dann kaufst du dir halt ein paar,
Festplatten und kopierst das da drauf und dann lässt du halt ein paar Skripts.
Da durchrauschen, lässt du, was weiß ich, Audioaufzeichnungen,
Transkript OCR und was nicht alles, suchst,
nach Passwörtern und so weiter, kannst du sogar mit einer lokalen KI machen
und so weiter und so fort.
Du hast auf einmal Unmengen an Infrastruktur und Architekturinformationen,
die du verwenden kannst.
Und vor drei Jahren waren das eben häufig Datenmengen, wo es ein unglaublicher
Aufwand gewesen wäre, sich dadurch zu wühlen.
Und jetzt ist es eine Datenmenge, die du, naja...
Es ist dir ja verhältnismäßig egal, wenn da irgendwie was weiß ich, dein,
Amazon GPU Cluster oder dein Mac Ultra oder was, da mal ein paar Tage heißen Dampf macht,
um diese Daten zu konsolidieren und da die Rosinen rauszupicken.
Und da sind eine Menge Rosinen drin.
Die du jetzt halt leichter findest. Das heißt, es hat sich auch verändert, dass diese,
während eventuell früher so eine Daten, die Datenmenge allein noch quasi deine
großen Geheimnisse waren da hidden in plain sight, immer noch,
hast du jetzt so eine Situation, wo du, und ich bin mir übrigens,
wenn du auf die Reseda-Leak-Seite gehst, die Zusammenfassung der Inhalte,
Die ließ sich für mich schon, ehrlich gesagt, so KI generiert.
Wo sie wahrscheinlich in der KI gesagt haben, hier, scan da mal bitte drüber
und sag mal ein bisschen juicy bits.
Und dann steht da ja auch so critical infrastructure, auf Kritis und das ist
sicherlich kein Begriff, der dieser Ransomware-Gruppe jetzt unbedingt geläufig ist.
Die wahrscheinlich sprengen ja noch nie mal die Sprache. Die haben gesagt, mach mal bitte.
Sag mal bitte auf Englisch, warum das hier nicht veröffentlicht werden sollte. Zack, bumm, fertig.
Ja, also ich meine jeder, der jetzt schon mal einen längeren Text in so einen,
AI-Chat reingeworfen hat und sich eine Zusammenfassung angeschaut hat,
kann sich glaube ich ganz gut vorstellen, was man eben aus solchen Datenmengen heraus machen kann.
Wir hatten ja hier auch schon diese neuen Security-Warnungen diskutiert, die jetzt
mit diesem Mythos-Level-Modellen von Cloud.com, die jetzt so als Fable und so
weiter, also sozusagen die aktuelle Generation, die ja nicht nur in der Lage ist,
aus Quellcode jetzt Fehler zu finden, das haben wir ja schon seit längerem gesehen.
Sondern auch daraus automatische Strategien abzuleiten, wie man so eine Kaskade
von einzelnen Fehlern nutzen kann, um Infiltrationen vorzunehmen.
Was die Systeme ja teilweise jetzt auch schon so eigenständig bei den Tests
machen, dann aus ihrer eigenen Sandbox ausbrechen und im Internet losmarschieren,
obwohl man ihnen gesagt hat, du das nicht, Junge.
Und mit dem Level an AI-Kombinatorik ist es natürlich jetzt unter Vorhandensein
von der vollständigen Beschreibung.
Passwörtern, Zugangslisten, Systemlisten, Beschreibungen, wie das alles zusammenhängt,
wer dafür zuständig ist und so weiter.
Also da kann man sich, mit diesen Daten kann man sich monatelang beschäftigen
und alle möglichen Angriffsszenarien daraus machen und dafür gibt es natürlich auch Kundschaft.
Ich meine, dass dieser Datenberg jetzt in Russland liegt und sorgfältig bearbeitet wird.
Ja.
Es ist einfach, selbstverständlich ist das so und findet das jetzt gerade statt
und wahrscheinlich auch nicht nur in Russland, sondern auch in den USA und sonst
wo und keine Ahnung. Und das ist halt sowohl jetzt für,
Staaten, die uns nicht so wohlgesonnen sind und vielleicht auch welche,
die uns eher wohlgesonnen sind interessant, sondern eben auch für kriminelle Gangs,
weil da kann man schon nochmal ein bisschen mehr nochmal erreichen.
Und eben jetzt mit einer, du hast gerade gesagt, kann man sich Monate mit beschäftigen,
braucht man aber nicht mehr.
Kann man jetzt halt in ein paar Tagen einfach mal kurz so ein Modellabflug schützen lassen.
Aber das wird noch über Monate so weitergehen, dass da ein paar Leute in ein paar Tage...
Du kriegst ja auch so ein, guck mal, wir hatten mal, wie gesagt,
wir betreuen das ja beruflich öfter, so was.
Da war ja quasi ein anstehendes Leak und da wussten, wir wussten eben auch aufgrund
der Cowboy-Mentalität, dass dieses Leak passieren würde und unsere Aufgabe war,
oder die Aufgabe des Teams war, findet die Secrets da drin, damit wir die rotieren können. Und dann.
Hat das Team eben auch gesagt, alles klar, wir machen jetzt eine Pipeline,
die danach sucht, wir bauen uns Tools und so weiter, wir transkribieren zum
Beispiel Aufzeichnungen, Zeichnungen, was eben alles so Sachen,
die du jetzt seit einiger Zeit halt hast.
Und wir machen eine Pipeline, die in Videos regelmäßig, wenn der Bildschirm
sich ändert, Screenshots OCRen lässt. Und dann suchen wir wieder nach,
wie sieht ein Passwort aus und so weiter.
Und dann am Ende war das Ergebnis in diesem Fall, okay, ist so viel,
wir rotieren einfach alles.
Und das hat jetzt Berlin eben auch vor sich. Die müssen eben alle Passwörter
rotieren, inklusive dieser 21.
Fun Fact, wenn genau dieses Problem nicht zu haben, dafür ist so ein Active Directory ganz gut.
Da kannst du nämlich an zentraler Stelle sagen, alles klar, das ist jetzt neu.
Und okay, was jetzt es ist,
es ist wie es ist, kauft Wasser, Berliner lagert Wasser ein,
der Russe weiß, wo der herkommt und ähm.
Ich warte immer noch darauf, dass es irgendwann mal jemand sagt,
ach so, okay, da müsste man mal was machen, weil das mit diesem Cyber,
das passiert ja wirklich.
Ich. Aber wahrscheinlich haben die auch in Berlin noch gedacht,
ja, wer sollte uns denn angreifen?
Ich meine, die Hacker kriegen doch von uns die Sozialhilfe, die werden doch
nicht irgendwie die Hand abbeißen, die sie füttert oder was auch immer,
die sich da gedacht haben, weißt du?
Lass uns zum nächsten Thema fortschreiten, das verbreitet auch wenig gute Laune.
Ja, wir haben,
Es ist ja jetzt schon fast eine Routine der USA geworden, Organisationen auf
diese Terrorlisten zu setzen.
Wir haben darüber berichtet, dass eben der Chefankläger und ich glaube weitere
Mitarbeiter am Internationalen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte auf diesen Sanktionslisten sind.
Wir haben auch darüber gesprochen, dass die Rote Hilfe und, was war das,
Antifa Nordost oder was,
randomly auf diesen Listen gelandet sind, die dann eben sehr,
sehr schwerwiegende Konsequenzen haben für diejenigen, die draufstehen.
Weil das eben unter anderem im Prinzip so gut wie jeder größeren regulierten
Institution verbietet, mit diesen Menschen Geschäfte zu machen.
Was eben dazu führte, hier bei dem Chefankläger vom Internationalen Gerichtshof
für Menschenrechte, dass der eben kein E-Mail mehr hatte, weil das bei Microsoft ist.
Und Microsoft eben sagt, wir müssen diese Sanktionslisten befolgen.
Oder dass eben dann die Banken der Roten Hilfe die Konten kündigen wollten,
weil sie gesagt haben, wir müssen das tun.
Und jetzt haben die USA auf die Terrorliste geschrieben,
eine Gruppe mit dem Namen Autistici Inventati,
haben sie also als globale Terroristen eingestuft und sagen,
das ist also jetzt notwendig, um der wachsenden Bedrohung durch gewalttätige,
linksradikale Terrorgruppen entgegenzuwirken.
So, was macht ähm,
Autistici Inventati. Die haben sich 2001 gegründet.
2001 war der G8-Gipfel in Genua. Autistici Inventati ist ja auch italienisch.
So eine Gruppe aus Indymedia Italien, die dann gesagt hat, okay, wir,
verschreiben uns dem Betreiben von freien Kommunikationsinfrastrukturen.
Das machen die ehrenamtlich und stellen eben sozialen Bewegungen,
E-Mail, Instant Messenger, selbstverwaltete Infrastruktur, Videokonferenzplattformen, solche Dinge.
Da gibt es solcher Kollektive durchaus viele.
Also RiseUp ist sicherlich auch sehr vielen bekannt oder SO36,
einfach Tech-Kollektive oder auch viele Gruppierungen, die dann zum Beispiel
Tor-Server betreiben oder so. da gibt es ja einfach relativ viele Kollektive.
Was die auch bereitgestellt haben, war die Domain NoBlogs.org,
wo du dann eben Blogs, wo du dir so einen Blog klicken konntest.
Und,
Ja, dann wurde diese Gruppierung eben als terroristische Vereinigung da benannt
und ich glaube nach zwei Tagen war die Domain halt weg,
weil keiner mehr sich getraut hat, im DNS diese Domain vorzuhalten,
weil dir droht eben unmittelbar ungemacht, weil du eben.
Eine Terrorgruppe unterstützt. Und die Gruppe hat sich anfänglich noch kämpferisch
gegeben und haben dann aber jetzt am 6.
September gesagt, okay, wir haben anfangs gesagt, dass wir so lange wie möglich
dem widerstehen werden.
Wir haben hier eine freie, privacy-friendly,
Infrastruktur für politisch committete Leute bereitgestellt.
Und wir haben aber jetzt festgestellt, dass wir als die ehrenamtlichen Betreiber
dieser Infrastruktur eben in eine derartig fürchterliche Zukunft blicken, wenn wir...
Also erstens können wir das gar nicht weiter betreiben, weil es gibt ja keine Domains mehr.
Es werden auch sicherlich weitere folgen. Die haben sehr viel mehr Domains als jetzt nur Autistici.
Und wir werden persönliche, legale und finanzielle Konsequenzen zu tragen haben und unsere Familien.
Die wir nicht tragen können. Und deswegen machen wir das jetzt platt.
Wir werden alles ausschalten. und die discontinue all of the services we provide.
Und die haben halt für ein Vierteljahrhundert eben Blogs, E-Mails und sonst
was bereitgestellt und was halt wirklich,
das Irrsinnige ist, ist halt, weißt du, bei allergrößte, die die hatten,
da waren schon, ich glaube, hunderte oder tausende Blogs, die sie dann über
die Zeit da bereitgestellt haben, ja.
Bei allergrößte, die die haben, ist es ja irrsinnig, dass sich irgendwie die
US-Regierung mit irgendeinem italienischen Tech-Kollektiv, die da,
weiß ich nicht, ein paar Server betreiben, auseinandersetzt und die auf die Terrorliste setzt.
Und das krasse ist, was natürlich jetzt auch passiert.
Das ist ja jetzt alles weg. Die tilgen damit eben auch einen großen Teil aus,
sagen wir mal, von Kommunikationsinfrastruktur und sonstigen,
die eine internationale, progressive Vernetzungsgesellschaft im Sinn hatten.
Oder wo eben auch viele linke oder linksradikale politische Inhalte ihre Heimat
gefunden hatten im Internet. Und das ist jetzt einfach weg.
Per Dekret. Und was man auch sieht, ist, dass jetzt wirklich sehr verhalten,
und da ist auch wieder so ein Aspekt, wo ich auch denke, da bin auch ich so,
wo ich denke, boah, Alter, wenn ich jetzt den Kopf zu weit rausstrecke, bin ich der Nächste.
Und genau das ist ja das, was so eine Aktion zum Ziel hat.
Dass das nächste Tech-Kollektiv sagt, Alter, okay,
vielleicht mal lieber nicht politischen Gruppen ehrenamtlich Infrastruktur bereitstellen.
Wer weiß, ob wir dann noch unser Bankkonto behalten können.
Ja, und das ist halt wirklich so diese,
Politik des,
Außennutzens eines globalen Hebels, wo sich dann Staaten auf einmal gar nicht
gegen wehren können, weil alles so miteinander vernetzt ist.
Ich meine, wir nutzen ja das auch gegen andere Staaten und so weiter.
Da kann man jetzt darüber argumentieren, ob das dann irgendwie gerechtfertigt
ist oder nicht. Das ist sicherlich in vielen Fällen schon, aber jetzt wird es
halt einfach von den USA missbraucht.
Ganz offensichtlich, weil alles, was ihnen jetzt sozusagen nicht in den Kram
passt, wie zum Beispiel Antifa, ja, das ist jetzt einfach mal der Feind.
Aber wir wissen ja alle, wenn du halt nicht Antifa bist, dann bist du halt Far.
Und das ist halt genau das, was jetzt eben gerade stattfindet.
Far-Milien-Fest.
Ja und die ähm.
Was ich auch denke ist, oder was man ja auch erkennen muss, es sind genauso
wie irgendwelche rechten YouTuber-Journalistinnen einschüchtern,
die im Rahmen ihrer Ausübung ihrer Pressefreiheit und Meinungsfreiheit,
die es im Land ja gar nicht mehr gibt,
um die, die sich ja auch so sorgen, ja, hier darf man gar nicht mehr sagen,
was man denkt, aber wenn da mal eine Journalistin auf dem Parteitag rumrennt,
dann muss man die sofort dafür sorgen,
dass sie in der eigenen Hassbubble gebranntmarkt ist und niedergeschrien wird.
Das ist die Meinungsfreiheit, von der sie träumen. Aber warum nehmen die USA
sich irgendein, wie gesagt, verhältnismäßig kleines Tech-Kollektiv in Italien?
Weil da halt genau keiner, der Aufschrei bleibt halt aus. Du brauchst ja nicht
zu meinen, dass jetzt Friedrich Merz sagt, nein, das geht nicht.
Das sind ja Linke. Das sollte schon längst mal weg.
Und das wiederum hat dann halt den Schilling-Effekt.
Weil wenn du einmal die Präzedenz geschaffen hast, dass es keinen Aufschrei
gab, dann weiß jeder andere, okay, bei uns wird es auch keinen geben.
Und wenn du und die Präzedenz, dass es keinen Aufschrei gab,
kriegst du auch durch die Salami-Taktik.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass im nächsten Monat die nächsten kommen.
Die Terrorgruppe. sollte sich jetzt mal nicht Friedrich Merz primär Gedanken
machen, sondern eigentlich eher Giorgio Meloni.
Keine Ahnung, wie das in Italien diskutiert wird tatsächlich.
Müssen wir mal gucken, ob sich da noch irgendwas draus ergibt.
Meine Hoffnungen sind da gering.
Andererseits sollte Europa natürlich jetzt in zunehmendem Maße mal merken,
woher hier der Wind weht.
Weil jetzt mag es ja noch die verhassten Linken treffen. Demnächst trifft es
dann halt andere Organisationen.
Und naja, dann ist es mal wieder alles zu spät.
Ja, also es ist,
ja.
Aber das Innenministerium will sich dann mit den USA zu einem Anti-Antifa-Treffen irgendwie treffen.
Ja, stimmt. Genau, das Innenministerium war irgendwie so eine Mary,
da gibt es jetzt dann irgendwann bald einen Anti-Antifa-Gipfel.
In den USA reisen wir dann an. Dafür haben wir Geld.
Workshop gegen Linksextremismus Entschuldigung, in Deutschland ist da Sparmageld die kommt zu uns.
Dein Freund Alexander Dobrindt.
Ich will ja nur sagen, den Politikverdross den kann ich nachvollziehen Ja.
Immerhin So, weitere schlechte Nachricht Jugend hackt eine Organisation,
die ihr sicherlich schon mal,
von der ihr bestimmt schon mal gehört habt, seit vielen Jahren,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange gibt es das jetzt schon, das geht jetzt auch schon sehr lange.
Also ich würde sagen mindestens zehn Jahre.
Ja, würde ich auch sagen.
Das könnte auch schon,
2013, 2013, 2013, 2014 oder so würde ich sagen.
13. Sagt das Internet. Genau, also seit 13 Jahren unterwegs, aber jetzt,
zuletzt haben sie vor allem vom Förderprogramm des BMBF gelebt,
Demokratie leben heißt das, aber da soll die Demokratie jetzt wohl nicht mehr
so ganz so lebendig sein,
deswegen sind ihnen die Förderungen gestrichen worden, das läuft alles zum Ende des Jahres aus.
Ja und da es eben keine Förderzusagen gibt fürs nächste Jahr,
wurde das Team schon von 9 auf 5 gekürzt.
Es wird Stand jetzt keine Hackathons mehr geben, keine Projekte und wenn nicht
ein Wunder geschieht, wie sie schreiben, dann ist im Juni 27 das Geld alle und das Licht geht aus.
Tja, das ist natürlich nicht so schön. JugendHakt ruft zu Spenden auf oder was
wahrscheinlich noch hilfreicher wäre.
Zuwendung von entsprechenden Organisationen, die aber auch über Geld verfügen.
Und ja, wir verlinken den Spendenlink von Jugendhackt, wenn ihr Lust habt,
euch dazu beteiligen und wenn ihr irgendwie Institutionen kennt,
die dieses Projekt vielleicht am Leben erhalten wollen, dann würden die sich
sicherlich auch über einen Kontakt freuen.
Ja, man muss ja noch ein bisschen, das Problem ist sogar noch größer,
dass wir berichten jetzt hier über den einzelnen Fall von Jugendhackt,
die, also was macht Jugendhackler, haben wir so als bekannt vorausgesetzt,
sie veranstalten eben Hackathon-Events für Jugendliche, wo sie dann,
ein in der Regel Programmier-Maker-Projekt realisieren an diesem Wochenende,
präsentieren, da gibt es eine Abschlusspräsentation und so,
und wo man eben diese Technik, den spielerischen Umgang mit Technik,
den kreativen Umgang mit Technik voranbringt. Das ist das, was die machen sollen.
Demokratie leben, das Förderprogramm vom BMBF, ist, wenn ich mich nicht täusche,
irgendwie mal von Angela Merkel oder unter Angela Merkel ins Leben gerufen worden
und quasi nach diesen NSU-Sachen.
Also nachdem wir gelernt hatten, dass die ganzen von der Polizei zu Unrecht
als geheime türkische bandenkriminelle,
beschuldigten Menschen einfach nur von einer Nazigruppe ermordet wurden.
Manuela Schwesig hat das ins Leben gerufen. Bundesfamilienministerium.
Ja, ja, aber unter Merkel.
Ja, ja, klar, damals war ja alles Merkel.
So, und dieses Demokratie-Leben-Förderprogramm, das sind eben diese, ja,
wo man verschiedene Förderziele hat zum Unterstützen der Demokratie.
Und einer davon war Vielfalt. Und die jetzige Familienministerin,
Karin Die hat dann gesagt, ja, okay,
Vielfalt ist jetzt kein staatliches Förderziel mehr. Und sie wollen sich eher
auf Sportvereine konzentrieren als auf Demokratieprojekte.
Sport lebt oder was ist das dann? es gab ja dann auch schon diese anderen Diskussionen
in dem Bereich die sogenannte Extremismusklausel wo dann immer alle,
Gruppierungen die da in der Förderung sind irgendwie nochmal genötigt wurden dass sie,
sich distanzieren von allem dass
sie sich genau auf die freiheitlich demokratische Grundordnung was auch,
so unsinnige Sachen sind,
und du kannst dich jetzt neu darauf bewerben, kannst du machen,
aber es hat eben jetzt neue Bedingungen. Und Jugend Hakt sind nicht die einzigen,
die darunter leiden. Es gibt auch so Organisationen wie die Amadeo Antonio Stiftung,
HateAid und andere, die eben.
Die da auch Förderungen hatten und die jetzt nicht mehr bekommen.
Und unter anderem sagen sie, das soll jetzt immer bundesweit sein.
Also sie möchten gerne bundesweite Projekte fördern, ja.
Und damit schließen ja quasi schon sehr viele Kleine aus. Und jetzt kommt aber.
Die Idee ist dann, wenn das für Lokale gerufen geht, dann geben sie die Förderung,
das Geld der Kommune, die das dann verwaltet.
Weil sie dann sagen, und die Kommune kann ja entscheiden, ob sie das annehmen.
Und jetzt hast du natürlich Kommunen, wo jetzt, sag ich mal,
CDU und AfD schon relativ stark sind.
Wenn einer sagt, hör mal hier, der Demokratieleben hat sich überlegt,
die wollen mal das alternative Jugendzentrum da fördern, dann sagt die Kommune
so, boah, weiß ich gar nicht, ob wir uns den Aufwand, das Geld zu verwalten,
ob wir das jetzt auch noch sehr eh schon alle hier hart überarbeitet.
Und das heißt, gerade die Demokratieprojekte, die leiden jetzt darunter.
Nochmal, das ist jetzt ein bisschen aus meiner Erinnerung und den Gesprächen
mit anderen Gruppierungen. Und das kann im Detail falsch sein,
insofern freue ich mich, oder gibt es sicherlich noch viele andere Gruppierungen,
die betroffen sind, die zu ergänzen sind.
Insofern freue ich mich auch hier über Ergänzungen in den Kommentaren,
weil das eben auch so ein Ding ist, weißt du,
wo so scheibchenweise diese Vollhirnies in einer Situation.
Wo rechtsradikale, verfassungsfeindliche Organisationen in Richtung 50 Prozent
in einem Bundesland marschieren, sagen die, ja, pass auf, da haben wir uns überlegt,
Demokratie machen wir jetzt lieber im Sportverein, bevor da noch irgendwelche Leute kommen,
mit politischer Demokratieindoktrination.
Das haben wir hier nicht so gerne.
Du kannst dir gar nicht vorstellen, in welche Hände wir dieses Land gegeben
haben. Oh, das wird so...
Wir müssen noch Termine, Termine. Komm, wir machen Termine.
Du regst dich sonst nur auf.
Ich habe schon wieder Bock. Also F in Berlin, vom 11. bis 13.
September, das ist jetzt, also für kurz entschlossen ein Termin.
Ich hatte den aber schon vor einiger Zeit mal angekündigt. Der Berliner Ferry Day.
Auf der Seabase. Zum dritten Mal.
Wo es also um die ganzen Ideen von Dezentralität, Föderalisierung und so weiter
geht. Wir haben es im Detail erklärt.
Glaube ich, habe ich schon vor einiger Zeit mal angekündigt und kann ich nur
empfehlen, auch kurz entschlossen mal am Wochenende auf der Base vorbeizuschauen.
Und dann halten vom am 17. und 18. Oktober hält Jugendhack den letzten oder
den hoffentlich nicht letzten Jugendhack-Kongress ab.
Und dann haben wir natürlich noch am 19.
November in Döbeln den Gerichtstermin für die Einhorn-Standarte.
Alright.
Dann war es das erstmal von uns für diese Woche.
Das waren die schlechten Nachrichten für heute. Ich würde sagen,
nächsten Sendungstermin können wir am Montag schon mal dann machen.
Wenn bis dahin nicht so viele Themen sich aufgestaut haben.
Wir gucken mal. Naja. Leute, Laune nicht verlieren. Ganz wichtig. Kopf hoch.
Pride Flagge an die Harley.
20. Also, du weißt schon, die goldenen 20er.
Noch ist es möglich. Wir tun alles dafür.
Alright, das war's. Bis bald.